faut que vous alliez voir sur les côtés
comment il tient à mon avis ça doit être
un genre étendage à linge tu vois quoi
[Musique]
il n'a pas été démonté depuis au moins
un siècle donc vous avez vu qu'il est
devenu le fond censé être blanc il est
devenu complètement jaune le problème
c'est que c'est absolument pas ce qui
nous attend au-dessus tu vois là au
dessus ça peut être une couche de
poussière comme ça c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux mais ça peut être cadavre de
souris cadavre d'oiseau
trésor
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du grand chantier pour la
famille de brosse
depuis 1717 tous leurs ancêtres ont vécu
au château de sa connais
tu peux épouster un peu le mur et depuis
bientôt 40 ans c'est Sandrine qui est la
maîtresse des lieux mais
vous répondrai pas un manche pour les
tenir en haut la nature
ma belle-mère un pas vécu là très très
longtemps puis mon beau-père était très
attaché c'est comme ça ça reste comme ça
on a vécu comme ça jusqu'ici donc il y a
pas de raison que ça continue pas il
avait pas mis le courant et pratiquement
pas de l'électricité donc voilà ça a pas
bougé puis c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident on peut le faire parce qu'on est
nombreux comme Sandrine et sa famille
les Français sont attachés à leur
patrimoine à travers le pays plus de
300000 objets ou bâtiments sont protégés
au titre des Monuments Historiques
beaucoup appartiennent à des
propriétaires privés qui se battent pour
les préserver mais tous ne sont pas
fortunés loin de là à Bar-le-Duc dans la
Meuse trois copains ont eu le coup de
cœur pour un théâtre à l'italienne voué
à la destruction Anthony Étienne et Loïc
viennent d'acquérir ce lieu exceptionnel
il rêve de le faire revivre et pour cela
ils vont tenter de mobiliser les
habitants de leur ville les travaux on
les voit on n'est pas idiots on les voit
on mesure ce qu'il y a à faire mais on
est séduit en fait donc du coup quand on
est séduit par quelqu'un on va forcément
le côté plus c'est côté positif que
négatif dans un premier temps
dans un petit village du Béarn Maëlle
éducateur spécialisé encadre un chantier
de rénovation pour des jeunes en
décrochage scolaire et ce bloc si elle
se bloque force pas sa mission leur
faire remonter un vieux moulin et
peut-être découvrir le plaisir des
métiers liés au patrimoine
enfin à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
de Lyon Sandrine Bruno et leurs enfants
rénove le château familial
cette année l'objectif de leur grande
famille est de restaurer la chapelle
laissé à l'abandon depuis un demi-siècle
et pendant que les hommes s'occupent du
gros œuvre dont les entrailles du
château Sandrine et les filles vont
partir à la chasse au trésor tu vois
regarde comme ça va être galère regarde
là on a deux mots
près de Lyon dans le Béarn ou à
Bar-le-Duc pendant près d'un an nous
avons suivi ces amoureux du patrimoine
[Musique]
au château de saconnay l'heure est au
démontage mais ce matin le lit à
baldaquin fait de la résistance
Sandrine se fait aider par Tanguy son
fils aîné
[Musique]
28 juin 1901
Sandrine et son mari Bruno vivent à
l'année dans ce château du 14e siècle
chaque été leur 5 enfants et leur
conjoint les rejoignent tous sont
mobilisés pour rénover le château
je vous signale que nous avons réussi à
descendre de baldaquin
c'est de mettre des journaux oui alors
c'est ce que je disais
un peu historiques c'est pas souvent que
j'ai tous mes jambes belles filles et
filles ensemble donc c'est des moments
privilégiés parce que je ne vis pas avec
les belles filles donc je les découvre
un peu je découvre mieux quand on fait
des travaux ensemble
cet été Bruno et ses trois fils se
lancent dans la restauration de la
chapelle au premier étage du château
[Applaudissements]
le travail ça fait une quarantaine
d'années que c'est comme ça au moins et
je n'ai rien été fait ici donc c'est
plus que temps de remettre en état ce
plafond une fuite sur le toit à
endommager ce plafond décoré il y a 200
ans l'inconnu aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir quelle partie du plâtre et des
couleurs d'origine vont pouvoir être
sauvés
donc on casse d'abord ça on sait faire
on est sur qu'on y arrivera vite une
fois que c'est vidé une fois que tout
est vidé et tout est protégé
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3 4 5 6
c'est impressionnant
ce soir on a fini je crois
Bruno ingénieur de formation a fait
carrière en organisant des chantiers et
pour le château il a formé ces trois
garçons dès leur enfance
les yeux là
il y a pas toutes les tomettes du
grenier qui ont suivi c'est déjà pas mal
de continuer en moins de 2h le plafond
laisse place à un trou béant
un peu de boulot quand même la partie
charpente
ça je suis je suis plus réservé
le plâtre à l'ancienne c'est la hantise
de Bruno mais la famille n'a pas le
choix faire appel à des professionnels
coûterait trop cher
l'enjeu est de taille car de nombreuses
autres pièces du château ont besoin
d'être restauré
Sandrine Bruno et leur famille se
donnent un an pour rénover la chapelle
dans les règles de la
en Lorraine Étienne Anthony et Loïc
s'attaquent eux à la rénovation d'un
autre lieu chargé d'histoire
les trois trentenaires se sont
rencontrés sur les bancs du lycée ils
viennent d'acheter cet ancien théâtre à
l'italienne construit en 1900 à
Bar-le-Duc leur ville d'origine
le lieu est à l'abandon depuis 20 ans
on va ouvrir le premier
[Musique]
le soleil vient de se lever
tu veux qu'on enchaîne aussi Anthony ou
pas
il parlait de le détruire donc on s'est
dit on va le voir une dernière fois on
va le voir dans quel état il est et on
verra ce moment là on va lui dire au
revoir en fait un petit peu et au moment
d'entrée on a dit mais non n'importe
quoi il est pas il est pas fichu ce
théâtre il y a vraiment moyen de de
mettre les mains dans le cambie
on s'attendait vraiment pas avoir des
choses aussi belles que ça à chaque fois
qu'on rentre on pose la lumière quelque
part et voilà boum on tombe sur ça par
exemple trouve ça super il y a une
petite lyre là qui est comme ça qui ça
fait 100 ans qu'elle est dessiné elle
est là elle est toujours là on se dit
que le théâtre on a l'impression qu'il a
attendu en fait ce moment là
les anciens fauteuils et la scène sont
encore cachés sous un plancher qui date
des années 70 à l'époque où le théâtre
avait été transformé en gymnase
la partie ici c'était tout l'orchestre
là donc c'est vraiment un théâtre qui
était musical donc ça c'est assez
intéressant pour la suite parce que ça
sera pas qu'un théâtre il y aura de la
musique et c'est intéressant de
restituer comme il était à l'origine
quoi après on a retrouvé des choses
ouvrir la petite trappe on allait être
de la souffleuse qui est juste là après
on retrouve la petite sonnette ou c'est
marqué rideau là juste là pour qu'elle
appelle le mec la régie
les travaux on les voit on n'est pas
idiots on les voit on mesure ce qu'il y
a à faire mais le côté positif et le fin
on est séduit en fait donc du coup qu'on
est suivi par quelqu'un on va forcément
le côté plus les côtés positifs que
négatifs dans un premier temps à
Bar-le-Duc ils sont nombreux à se
souvenir de ce théâtre qui a survécu à
deux guerres et endurer l'occupation
dans leur grenier certains habitants ont
même retrouvé des photos et des affiches
ils les ont offertes aux nouveaux
repreneur pour les aider à redonner vie
à celui emblématique
c'est énorme ça faut absolument qu'on
Étienne est chargé de projet dans la
communication
Anthony et comédien héloïc bijoutier les
trois amis consacrent tout leur temps
libre et leur week-end à ce projet ils
doivent trouver près de 900 000 euros et
pour cela il paraît sur la mobilisation
des habitants de Bar-le-Duc ce soir plus
de 400 personnes ont répondu présentes à
la première soirée qu'ils organisent au
profit du théâtre
il y a quelqu'un qui vous place tout va
bien
ça va oui très bien merci
les bénéfices vont rentrer dans la
cagnotte en plus de celle qui est sur
internet pour l'instant pour commencer à
faire les premiers travaux et les
différentes étapes pour le bâtiment
Nicole
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on peut garder
sauvegarde c'est très bien
je l'ai surtout connu pour avoir la
guerre c'est des souvenirs de gauche et
en principe les souvenirs de gauche ça
ne s'oublie pas
ce soir Anthony le comédien de la bande
et sur scène avec quelques amis
[Musique]
pour assister à cette soirée chaque
spectateur a fait un don de 25 euros
[Musique]
2500 pages sur facebook 4000 visites sur
notre site et
11500 euros récoltés en trois semaines
c'est fou merci à vous
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec avec
cette première cagnotte ce qu'on appelle
de fond c'est tout simplement mettre le
bâtiment hors d'eau c'est super
important s'il y a quelques fuites et on
a calculé que vous êtes 400 ce soir ce
qui fait 800 bras si on se met tous ce
soir je pense qu'on peut inaugurer
demain vers 13h
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain matin une quarantaine de
curieux sont venus voir par eux-mêmes ce
théâtre endormi
qui est déjà venu ici
quel souvenir vous gardez vous l'avez
connu
en 1900 et il a été construit par un
architecte qui est Monsieur Morel qu'on
lui doit quelque chose et on serait pas
là s'il avait pas été là c'est que vu
qu'il faisait des travaux publics mais
il l'a fait en béton le théâtre donc ça
c'est vraiment une chance qu'on a c'est
que d'avoir une structure super saine et
super solide
mais bon on est aussi fou que nous on
reste encore quelque chose à la Villotte
aussi donc voilà mais c'est une bonne
idée on les soutiendra ça c'est sûr
on va passer au deuxième étage prochaine
étape pour les trois amis organisé des
chantiers bénévoles pour accélérer le
rythme des travaux nous espérons que la
visite vous a plu Loïc Anthony et
Étienne vont devoir se transformer en
chef de chantier
salut Maëlle ça va très bien et toi
tranquillement à plus de 900 km de là à
Pau un autre chantier très particulier
débute
Maël aussi est un passionné de
patrimoine éducateur spécialisé il
emmène ce matin un groupe de jeunes de
quartiers défavorisés
Maëlle va les conduire au coeur du Béarn
dans le petit village d'os en as où
vivent 300 habitants
et après vous aimez équipe en tenue de
chantier
ces jeunes
âgés de 17 à 21 ans sont en décrochage
scolaire
tes chaussures elles sont derrière ça
convaincus par Maëlle ils ont accepté de
participer à un chantier de sauvegarde
du patrimoine régional
première consigne chaussures de sécurité
mais il va y en avoir d'autres un peu
plus haut vous allez voir
Maëlle a été formé par des Compagnons du
devoir mais pour ce chantier il sera
accompagné d'artisans spécialisés de la
région vous avez vu ce cadre un peu j'ai
vu cette montée surtout
[Rires]
le projet auquel ils vont consacrer tout
leur été c'est la restauration de ce
vieux moulin en ruine depuis plus de 35
ans
qu'il faut marcher dessus et se
suspendre donc du coup
il y en a qui vont se retrouver
au-dessous donc il faut faire hyper
gaffe parce que les pièces elles sont
lourdes il faudra remettre tout de
niveau à l'origine de ce chantier
patrimonial Gérard burst le maire du
village la commune investit plus de 60
000 euros pour redonner vie à ce lieu
chargé d'histoire là alors ça représente
le plan de tous les moulins qui avait à
hosalas celui qui nous intéresse il est
là vous l'avez reconnu sa position voilà
très bien alors regardez comment ça
marchait tu avais moulin l'eau est
repartez par un autre canal d'irrigation
qui était récupérée par ce moulin et
ainsi de suite récupérer dans l'autre
molaire et voilà et il y avait 14
moulins c'est ça qui est intéressant sur
les 14 moulins il n'a plus qu'un seul
voilà c'est un état de marche donc on va
le sauvegarder le restaurer c'est pour
là vous êtes là c'est intéressant pour
vous et de savoir qu'après il va être
visité par les touristes voilà par
contre ces plans
1800 40
alors le moulin il est daté
d'avant la Révolution
on va réceptionner ça ressemble le
moulin qui existait il y a 300 ans
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
à l'atelier communal Maëlle initie deux
jeunes au travail du bois pour
l'élaboration de la nouvelle charpente
ici
toutes les pièces que vous avez là sur
les établis et par terre c'est tout les
pièces qu'on voit ici la pièce qui
remonte le poinçon là celle-ci la poutre
Larba l'arbalète rappelle-toi l'arbalète
et donc c'est l'arbalétrier la poutre
là-bas pour la tirer réhabiliter un
moulin délabré en quelques mois avec des
ouvriers n'ayant jamais manié d'outils
le défi paraît difficile à relever mais
malgré leur côté désinvoltes les jeunes
pourraient bien surprendre Maëlle et les
habitants du petit village
2 3
mets-le sur l'épaule
attention
posez-le sur le rebord
venez là
[Musique]
à partir de peupliers de la région
où on est la charpente pèse plus de 800
kg le travail est éprouvant pour les
jeunes
ça va ça
il a pris ma place
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça
normalement je devais me coucher
appelle-moi boss on sera dans les délais
avec Maëlle et les autres non
pour restaurer le moulin dans les temps
Maëlle va devoir tenir son chantier
d'une main de fer prochaine étape la
remise en eau
[Musique]
au château de saconnais grâce à la
présence de ses fils le chantier de
Bruno avance bien
ok moi je trouve ça très sympa je sais
pas mais
je trouve ça très agréable
pendant ce temps Sandrine et ses belles
filles continuent leur chasse au trésor
et vont de surprises en surprise j'ai
trouvé ce carton
de la couturière
et ça ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
d'abord c'est des morceaux ça peut être
évident de retrouver
si ces morceaux de soie ont un jour
composé une robe d'époque il n'y a aucun
patron dans la boîte qui indique comment
les réassembler on suppose que c'est une
manche non je pense pas
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il y a
deux jupes une jupe dessous et une qui
doit se relever par dessus
finalement on sera peut-être le chantier
le plus compliqué ça connaît
oui et puis là on peut toujours regarder
le montage robe Louis XV on trouvera
rien
comment vous appelez ça avec des mots
des mots de voilà
depuis 40 ans Sandrine et son mari Bruno
consacre toute leur énergie et leurs
moyens à la restauration de leur château
un choix de vie que leurs enfants ont
mis du temps à accepter
d'abord on a eu grand-père ici pendant
un mois
d'adolescence quand au lieu d'aller
chouiller enfin d'aller faire la fête
avec des amis on va transporter des
tuiles pour réparer des fuites quand on
n'a pas encore conscience de la chance
qu'on a et ben ça c'est un peu compliqué
quoi ouais mais non tu peux passer une
nuit ici quand il pleut il pleut pas
dans ton lit là j'en suis conscient
c'est quand même magnifique c'est un
grand progrès j'en suis conscient à 37
ans j'étais moins en saison
un peu fier
aujourd'hui la reconstruction du plafond
de la chapelle peut commencer
Michel un plâtrier à la retraite qui
habite le village voisin a accepté de
donner un coup de main
une aubaine pour Tanguy l'aîné de la
famille
[Applaudissements]
militaire de carrière il a fait la route
depuis Lyon pour assister à cette leçon
de plâtre à l'ancienne
a priori en fait ils mettaient des
planches en bois en dessous il coulait
par dessus
[Musique]
on voit ici là
ça les 5 mm là c'est juste le plâtre
qu'on a mis par en dessous et tout ça là
c'est de la chaux qui a été écoulé par
dessus
faites attention parce que certains
partenaires
salut Thomas
c'est bien c'est bien ouais c'est
agréable de regarder travailler ça
toujours l'air vachement simple quand on
regarde ferme alors en pratique quand on
a l'outil dans les mains c'est
le plâtre que je redoute
qui nous apporte son savoir-faire
puis c'est fait dans les règles de l'art
ça fait correctement donc il s'était
bien aussi bon lui il a fait ça moi j'ai
fait ça
c'est pas mal on a égalité je me
rapproche quoi non mais bon pour une
première fois
alors que les travaux avancent dans la
chapelle Sandrine elle est en plein
doute le mystère de la robe d'époque lui
résiste depuis plusieurs semaines si je
sers à la taille
c'est affreux parce que
c'était fixé comment ce truc parce que
c'était cousu sur le manteau alors ça je
ne sais pas
j'ai une amie qui m'a prêté ce livre qui
est très bien parce qu'il y a des il y a
des patrons mais j'ai pas retrouvé mes
pièces ça je l'ai pas je sais pas ce que
c'est ça je l'ai pas ça je l'ai pas je
pense que ça doit être un corset il y a
des morceaux que j'ai et que je trouve
pas là ben parce que j'imagine que
chaque couturière devait avoir sa façon
de faire c'était pas un patron pareil
pour tout le monde alors des bandes
comme ça il y en a plein et si vous
regardez de près
vous voyez qu'elles ont été plissées il
va falloir que je refasse tous les plis
quand j'aurai tous les plis je serai
quelle est la longueur de la bande et du
coup je serai si c'est une bande qui se
met autour du cou et qui descend de
chaque côté du manteau qui se met pour
décorer le corsage c'est difficulté sont
pourtant loin d'entamer sa motivation
j'ai envie de voir comment était cette
robe elle devait être belle je raisonne
pas en patrimoine je raisonne plutôt
en plaisir de voir cet objet comme comme
il était autrefois oui bien sûr ça fait
partie du patrimoine puis surtout ça
montre à nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants qu'on fait quelque chose
que il y a ici des très belles choses et
qu'on se contente pas de les ranger des
thésauriser bien dans des placards qu'on
fait quelque chose avec
qu'on travaille pour laisser quelque
chose de bien pour la génération
suivante il y a aussi ça
côté chapelle avec l'aide de Michel le
plafond sera égalisé en un peu plus
d'une semaine il faudra ensuite attendre
que liverpo passe et que le plâtre sèche
avant d'envisager de refaire les
peintures et les pochoirs étoilés
nouvelle grille
d'un artisan en fait qu'il a fait
entièrement pour nous
et du coup ça amène de la lumière et
puis c'est au petit plus plus élégant
Étienne
on va peut-être nettoyer t-il là où
Monsieur ils ont coupé parce qu'il y a
des merdes et ils sont déjà chaud aussi
pour mettre l'échafaudage et retirer
tout c'est le plâtre et le faux plafond
des large aussi à Bar-le-Duc dans la
Meuse
faute de moyens la rénovation du théâtre
démarre lentement
[Applaudissements]
mais trois chantiers bénévoles ont
permis d'avancer dans le nettoyage et
l'assainissement du bâtiment
en quelques mois un noyau dur de
bénévoles s'est formé
ce matin ils sont une trentaine prêt à
se mettre au travail
même s'il y a beaucoup de monde faut
quand même être super organisé et puis
voilà il faut comme les gens ils sont
chauds dès le matin il faut les
réveiller ça met l'ambiance et c'est
vite parti là ça donne le rythme pour la
journée
c'est pas évident en fait il faut
s'adapter en fonction des personnes les
femmes on va pas les faire du béton armé
et puis voilà donc il faut essayer de
dispatcher en fonction des capacités des
gens Antoine est parti chercher
l'aspirateur d'accord
c'est un peu trop pour accéder
Étienne le moins bricoleur des trois
copains qui ont repris le théâtre se
chargent de faire connaître l'histoire
du bâtiment au curieux de passage on
profite de l'occasion pour faire un peu
de relation publique expliquez le projet
voilà c'est vrai que voilà on voit que
bénévoles sont assez autonome il y a pas
mal de gens donc c'est vrai que moi je
suis plus spécialisé là-dedans c'est un
beau projet c'est si bien de faire
revivre un monument comme ça
je connaissais pas du tout c'est la
première fois je mets les pieds dedans
et c'est assez impressionnant
impossible de penser que ce sera un
théâtre
les petites guirlandes là avec des
espèces de petites boules entre les
feuilles c'est les petits détails qu'on
voit pas d'en bas et que je trouve
magnifique vu d'ici c'est ça
étudiante en histoire de l'art est une
bénévole de la première heure
comme ça qu'on a découvert et ça nous
permet de nous approprier le lieu et je
trouve c'est quelque chose de formidable
on redécouvre le théâtre on a
l'impression de replonger dans le passé
et je trouve que c'est vraiment
formidable
au fil des week-ends les bénévoles sont
toujours plus nombreux parmi eux de
nombreux professionnels du bâtiment
offrent leur temps leur compétences et
leur matériel c'est le cas d'Antoine
venu couler du béton dans les loges
et le weekend c'est les bras la semaine
je vais travailler les autres
tu vois les inspecteurs les travaux
finis
[Musique]
par intérêt pour le patrimoine les
bénévoles reviennent aussi pour
l'ambiance qui règne sur les chantiers
au mois de novembre on a pu les 30
degrés de l'été et il y a toujours
autant de personnes qui viennent le
week-end nous aider c'est si on roule
tous ces bénévoles sur les week-ends sur
les trois premiers on était déjà 1300
heures de travail et 1300 heures de
travail si c'était des salariés
aujourd'hui on pourrait pas se le
permettre donc
c'est émouvant c'est touchant c'est de
se dire que on peut presque tout leur
demander
et ils sont là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les premiers chantiers ont pu être
assurés par les bénévoles mais la suite
va devoir être confiée à des entreprises
et gérer par un architecte car les
normes d'accueil du public dans un
théâtre sont contraignantes un
cheminement qui va partir donc du
parking haut on aura donc le
stationnement PMR utiliser cet
architecte c'est Dominique Millet parmi
ses priorités l'obtention du permis de
construire et la recherche de
financement
on sera en dessous d'un million d'euros
je pense
800000 euros
avec des plans qui nous appelle tous les
jours pour dire vraiment à sorcine
réunion à cette heure-là
ça fait pas peur au contraire ça existe
[Musique]
dans le Béarn la passion du patrimoine
semble aussi avoir atteint les jeunes de
peau le moulin laissé à l'abandon depuis
plus de 35 ans reprend petit à petit
forme dans la bonne humeur
[Musique]
les jeunes encadrés par Maëlle ont posé
4500 ardoises en schiste
ah c'est bien tu as compris ça rentre
allez
et on jointait le mur de pierre à la
chaux
la bâtisse quasi terminée l'équipe doit
maintenant trouver le moyen de ramener
de l'eau pour alimenter le moulin
il faut que tu arrives à tout dégager au
fur et à mesure là regarde vendre sur
mes épaules
canal ont été creusées curés avec une
petite pelle mécanique la semaine
dernière et là on se retrouve sur une
partie très étroite ou bien on n'a pas
le choix mais il va falloir mettre plus
d'huile le coude et on va faire on va
curer ce canal à la main enlever le
sable des cailloux qui ont été posées là
par la rivière et de façon à trouver un
point un point haut à l'entrée un point
bas de façon à avoir un écoulement quoi
qu'est-ce que vous faites de beau
on a tous les anciens qui viennent de
quelle ville il y a beaucoup d'anciens
on dit des anciens ici
on est la petite curiosité l'animation
on va dire sur le village
après la petite difficulté quand même
c'est arrivé à être en relation avec les
personnes et arriver aussi à ce que le
chantier mais il avance quoi
vous arrivez au bon moment les gars
ouais
c'est le premier test ouais est-ce que
ça monte là bas regarde vous avez vous
pouvez aller là-bas ouvrir allez chef tu
peux ouvrir
allez où
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est le début de la remise
40 ans
je pense que là il y en a qui vont être
surpris cet après-midi en passant
l'eau va permettre d'actionner la roue à
aube qui se trouve sous le moulin
mais avant cela Maëlle attend une visite
importante André un meunier de la région
doit faire un diagnostic des réparations
qui restent à effectuer tout ce
fonctionnement
je pense et les nouvelles qu'il apporte
ne sont pas bonnes
l'état de bonne
l'axe par contre moi je le changerai et
également ce qu'il faut changer c'est de
support donc le support c'est parti là
cette partie là ça veut dire que en fait
il faut tout démonter
voilà est-ce que vous le sentez faire le
palan bon très bien
l'inauguration est prévue dans quelques
jours l'équipe va devoir redoubler
d'efforts pour que le moulin tourne
au château de sa connais 8 mois ont
passé depuis les premiers coups de pelle
dans la chapelle et la découverte de
morceaux d'une robe du 18e siècle Albane
oui tu pourrais me donner un coup de
main pour fixer le vin
tu viens avec nous
en ce début des vacances de printemps
les travaux reprennent
[Musique]
dans un siècle du foot du foot du foot
astronaute qui n'arrête pas ça ça peut
être rigolo oui
pour aller sur la Lune
les yeux tout un plat d'aller dans
l'espace bah écoute c'est bien comme ça
à nouveau enfant et beaux enfants ont
répondu présent
juste le temps de nous positionner avec
les balais en dessous
j'ai oublié de fixer le fond là
je suis désolé j'ai complètement oublié
il en reste là
ah merde
[Musique]
très bien là c'est parfait
maintenant quand même quand on regarde
ça fait mieux qu'avant je trouve on voit
que c'est propre
par contre est-ce que je vais regarder
quoi
le chantier de la chapelle a lui aussi
bien avancé les peintures et finitions
sont en cours une activité qui demande
patience et minutie
c'était une longue histoire les étoiles
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'essais de
pochoirs
un petit plastique léger ça bave étant
que ça pouvait c'était l'horreur
complète après on refait des pochoirs
avec un carton c'était encore pire le
carton de pomper la peinture il y en
avait partout et finalement avec un
plastique assez épais découpé alors il y
a des retouches à faire après le puits
de retouche enfin pas grand chose
je sais pas comment ils ont fait à
l'origine mais la chute la chute qu'on a
gardé là les étoiles sont irréprochables
ils ont entendu tu es sûr que tu
pinailles pas là tu vas reprendre toutes
les étoiles des unes après les autres là
j'ai repris toutes les étoiles les unes
après les autres depuis le début là j'en
avais compté j'en étais là
7 minutes ou 6 minutes par étoile non il
y a 150 étoiles 250 et dis-moi Tanguy si
tu lève et bien du premier coup j'ai pas
réussi à avoir un rendu satisfaisant dès
le premier coup
pour que le blanc soit blanc il faut
deux couches
tu
je prends beaucoup de photos et de
petites filles parce que j'alimente un
profil Facebook de sa connaît un site
Internet toutes les semaines j'essaye de
poster une photo ou un film ou et puis
en plus je vais vous dire des voir tous
les trois travaillés ensemble moi je
trouve ça très sympa j'aime bien l'idée
que bah que mon mari et mes fils ils
font des trucs ensemble
ça prouve qu'ils ont pas rejeté leurs
parents
s'approchant les a pas dégoûtés de sa
colère pas d'écouter des travaux pas des
goûters
[Rires]
ces travaux la famille les finances
seuls mais pour les phases plus
imposantes comme la réflexion des
toitures impossible de faire sans l'aide
de subventions ou de Mécène privée pour
les attirer sandrine a créé un site
internet
bientôt elle pourra aussi poster des
nouvelles de l'assemblage de sa robe
après des mois d'essai elle semble enfin
terminée mais elle tient d'abord à la
montrer à sa petite fille et la surprise
va être de taille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon là tu vas descendre mais pas à fond
tu essaieras de garder trois ou quatre
centimètres vas-y descends doucement
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon essaie de la descendre
davantage allez touche plus tu restes là
agitation inhabituelle ce matin dans le
vieux théâtre de Bar-le-Duc voilà juste
une découverte là là parce qu'il faut
qu'on puisse passer entre les deux là
une surprise se prépare pour fêter une
année d'effort et de restauration de cet
édifice construit en 1900
moi j'ai joué une des dernières pièces
qui a été jouée ici c'était la farce de
l'homme mordu en 1968 quelque chose
comme ça 68 69
dans les dernières années
mais il y avait tout le temps des
spectacles des troupes nationales mais
aussi des spectacles du cru vraiment
beaucoup ah c'était ce qu'on va faire
aussi formidable Etienne est quelques
bénévoles sont venus prêter main fortes
à Mamie Poirier la metteuse en scène de
la troupe qui étreinera la salle avec
les femmes savantes de Molière
pour l'instant c'est du provisoire
magnifique que tous les bénévoles ont
installé vous voyez on a on n'a pas de
ciel mais on y a quand même accroché nos
planètes enfin on essaie de faire
l'illusion du théâtre parce que
finalement le théâtre ça n'est
qu'illusion c'est la magie
aux portes les travaux sont encore loin
d'être terminés mais grâce à la
débrouille de l'équipe le public
d'aujourd'hui profitera du spectacle
bien assis
c'était une belle occasion qui est
tombée
sur Facebook parce que c'était le
Théâtre de Bordeaux théâtre des
Salinières qui ont pas de se séparer de
ses anciens fauteuils donc ils ont dit
bon on les donne enfin il est vendait et
vu que la démarche a plu ils nous ont
dit bah allez-y venez les chercher et on
vous les donne donc on était les
chercher on avait 200
la bonne occasion
durant les mois écoulés des travaux
préparatoires ce sont déroulés au
théâtre à l'automne une première phase
de gros œuvre sera conduite par des
professionnels mais pour l'heure tout
doit être parfait pour recevoir les
spectateurs
[Musique]
voilà c'est bon on est prêt
sur les trois copains à l'origine du
projet selon Tony Le Parisien est
comédien de la bande n'a pas encore vu
la salle aménager
la surprise on est pas mal
ça fait quelque chose parce que quand on
est arrivé on était vraiment dans un pas
dans une mais dans un état vraiment
d'abandon on a eu les chantiers
bénévoles là on est vraiment dans un
contexte artistique c'est à dire que le
théâtre vient au théâtre quoi il
retrouve son âme je crois que c'est plus
beau cadeau qu'on peut faire et aux
donateurs qui sont derrière nous mais
également au théâtre quoi ça va être ça
va être une grande émotion
[Musique]
au cours de cette année en plus des
travaux les trois amis ont monté le
dossier de leur permis de construire et
chercher des financements bonjour à tous
vous voulez vous dire qu'on était
vraiment très très très très très très
heureux d'être avec vous et de vous
savoir avec nous aujourd'hui vous savez
que c'est super important de vous
associer à au projet pour nous vous
sentir derrière nous c'est c'est notre
moteur en fait tout ça sans vous ce
serait impossible
pendant ce temps à l'étage dans l'ancien
foyer du théâtre les comédiens se
préparent avec les moyens du bord
comme les loges ne sont pas du tout
prêtes à l'emplacement prévu et ben on
fait ce qu'on peut on s'arrange on joue
un peu Molière dans le fond
on fait comme si on n'a pas son talent
mais on a les mêmes conditions de vie
s'il vous plaît donc voilà en fait la
petite surprise on peut pas venir tous
l'avoir en même temps c'est une petite
surprise qui dit une petite douzaine de
minutes donc on vous propose de faire
deux groupes il y a un déjà un groupe de
60 personnes qui va descendre avec moi
pendant que l'autre va pouvoir prendre
un verre et après on inverse s'il reste
suffisamment de choses à voir et à
manger donc je propose qu'il y a un
groupe qui viennent avec moi s'il vous
plaît 60 personnes allez on y va
[Musique]
mettons-nous ici pour écouter
un peu mais il y a tellement de stress
autour de l'accueil pourquoi les gens
ils sont bien est-ce qu'ils ont le petit
saucisson on essaie de tout faire mieux
pour que en plus du spectacle est bien
accueilli qu'on les fidélise au final
quoi
dans l'émotion avec nous c'est vraiment
une phase de communion c'est que 100 ans
c'est pas n'importe quelle salle tu es
un spectacle là il est tellement tout
autour de toi
ne vous piquez que le savoir charme mais
avec près de 500 donateurs et le soutien
de la Fondation du Patrimoine
Anthony Loïc et Étienne ont déjà réuni
près de 150000 euros sur les 900 000
nécessaires
le million ce soir
il y en a un
format attendre un petit peu mais en
fonction des phases on espère pouvoir
ouvrir un deux trois ans
ah c'est merveilleux
[Applaudissements]
grâce à ces trois passionnés le théâtre
a échappé à la destruction pour Anthony
Loïc et Étienne le chemin est encore
long mais il ne sont plus seuls
désormais toute une communauté les
accompagne pour faire revivre ce
patrimoine de Bar-le-Duc
merci au bénévoles qu'on participe à
l'organisation cet événement merci
[Applaudissements]
de vous merci
dans la vallée d'Aspe le moulin
abandonné et lui aussi sur le point de
renaître
Maëlle le responsable du chantier et ses
apprentis s'affaire aux dernières
finitions
a lieu dans quelques heures
on a juste à repositionner deux carreaux
sur la fenêtre
et reposer la fenêtre c'est bon mais le
plus important reste à faire il faut
contrôler que le mécanisme du moulin
fonctionne encore après des années
d'inertie
[Musique]
encore oui ça fonctionne
allez c'est bon c'est bon
allez on voit bien qu'elle tournevis
[Musique]
et on peut applaudir
mon travail qu'on a fait là bon ça va
[Applaudissements]
quatre mois après le début des travaux
les habitants du village redécouvrent le
moulin tel qu'il était il y a 300 ans
vous pouvez prendre une pelleté je vais
vous photographier avec
le champion ça fait plaisir de voir
c'était une ruine
c'est du beau travail merci ils sont
contents comme nous on est content de
notre travail
mesdames messieurs merci beaucoup pour
Gérard le maire du village à l'origine
du projet l'opération est une réussite
aujourd'hui c'est la restauration totale
du moulin
il est notre fierté
puisqu'il a existe pratiquement plus
restaurer ce moulin
au-delà de la préservation du patrimoine
bâti
c'est rendre hommage aux hommes et
femmes qui ont façonné notre village
bravo encore les jeunes merci pour votre
implication si ça vous donne envie de
faire un de ces métiers un jour
[Applaudissements]
demain les jeunes retourneront chez eux
dans la banlieue de Pau fier d'avoir
participé à l'histoire de son aspect
alors on va mettre ça
tu vas voir c'est trop
au château de saconnay aussi
l'enthousiasme et de rigueur la robe
Louis XVI s'est révélée être une robe de
style Louis XV et elle est enfin
terminée
voilà on les met sur les épaules et toi
tu veux te mettre devant tu ramènes les
deux parties devant d'accord par dessus
le jupon
peut-être rapprocher un peu
là je vais faire un point là et un point
là
ça vous fait plaisir de la voir
je suis super contente
je crois qu'on est on est assez fidèle à
scalaire
et puis en plus elle est belle c'est
vrai que c'est magnifique
je voyais pas du tout ce que ça allait
donner et c'est vrai que je suis
vraiment impressionnée partout au
travail surtout en plus ah oui j'ai
vraiment passé beaucoup beaucoup de
temps pour faire tous les petits
bouillonnés tous les petits plis puis
quelques fois j'étais obligé de défaire
ce que j'avais fait parce que ça ça
allait pas j'ai vraiment passé beaucoup
de temps
mais ça grand plaisir comme si on avait
découvert un trésor vous voyez
par hasard on ouvre une boîte
et on trouve ça
concret l'histoire qu'ils apprennent
dans les livres c'est concret oui
j'avais une grand-mère qui portait une
robe comme ça d'ailleurs elle est là
on dit pas qu'elles ont été portées là
on peut se dire bah oui il y a même une
tâche donc on sait que la deuxième tâche
absolument
[Rires]
après le début des travaux la chapelle
était aussi terminée
bon on va mettre ça
quand tu vois le nuage qui sort il dit
que ça vaut la peine
un peu c'est moi qui fait tout là
je suis très contente
c'est propre
ouais c'est bien par contre après pour
tout ranger
ça servait un petit peu de débarrasse
cette pièce et il va falloir qu'on
la respecte un peu plus que ça qu'on
mette pas des tas de merde dans tous les
coins alors cette cagettes là c'est des
souvenirs c'est les restes de l'ancien
vitrail qui avait sur les fenêtres il y
a plusieurs morceaux et puis monsieur à
garder des restes de l'ancien plafond
avec l'ancienne couleur exacte bon c'est
comme ça pour m'amuser je mets ça sur
l'hôtel caché je dirais son futur dans
découvrir ensemble ils ont chouette un
trésor super elles sont peut-être un peu
déçus quand elles verront ce que c'est
là il est bon maintenant
les deux reliquaires des deux lampes je
crois que c'est tout ça faut le mettre
sur les hôtels aussi sainte adeoda
ça aussi ça c'est quoi ça ça aussi c'est
une petite relique Vincent de Paul
ah par contre il faut qu'on décide où on
met le confessionnal
[Musique]
dans une dans quelle
si on garde un confessionnal c'est dans
la chapelle sinon il y a pas de
confessions
on est d'accord pour dire combien de
console là donc on peut déjà enlever ça
et ça voilà très bien
résultats
tout l'ensemble plafond j'y croyais pas
trop au départ ah oui le plafond est top
professionnel
[Musique]
c'est le même boulot multiplié par 10
mais c'est possible
le chantier de Sandrine Bruno et leurs
enfants est encore grand mais ils
viennent de recevoir une bonne nouvelle
on va commencer où est le maire de
saint-sa
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît si vous voulez vous mettre en rang
en face
le projet de réhabilitation du château a
été sélectionné par une association cet
après-midi les responsables viennent
leur remettre la somme de 15000 euros
on a pu avoir
celle subvention qui sert par rapport à
tout ce beau besoins et modestes mais
souvent lorsque nos amis américains ont
distingué une demeure en France il lui
apporte une belle publicité et ça vous
donne
un outil supplémentaire pour aller
trouver d'autres aides c'est une belle
histoire et merci beaucoup de nous
l'avoir fait connaître
voici la plaque que vous pourrez poser à
l'entrée du château mais c'est toi qui
la mettra
pour changer de dimension
avant on était tout seul devant nos
problèmes puis là ça touche énormément
et puis on dit on va y arriver pour la
famille de brosse ce prix est une
reconnaissance du travail accompli
depuis 40 ans pour sauvegarder le
château de sa connais
c'est pas ringard ce qu'on fait il y a
des gens qui trouvent que c'est bien ah
non c'est je comprends qu'il soit moi ça
me fait plaisir pour lui parce que là il
va se mettre à bosser dix fois plus
ouais c'est un super stimulant